[Musica]
voglio parlarvi oggi della mia visione
di start up di azienda e la mia visione
è quella del viaggio perché fare una
start up per un'azienda è un viaggio
bellissimo
un viaggio lungo fino di difficoltà ma
si ha un obiettivo ben preciso da
raggiungere e si vuole fare di tutto per
ottenerlo infatti chi erano i grandi
imprenditori del passato le vere
rockstar delle start up di una volta
erano i grandi commercianti soprattutto
quelli marittimi quelli che sfidavano
tutto e tutto rischiavano la vita
rischiavano tutto in viaggi lunghi mesi
ma sapevano che sarebbero tornati con
immense ricchezze nuovi prodotti è anche
cultura per le proprie comunità e quindi
partivano non rischiavano andavano è il
tema del viaggio è importante anche per
la mia famiglia perché negli anni trenta
mio nonno parte da un piccolissimo paese
del friuli e viaggia rischia va in
sudafrica
una terra selvaggia aspra e inesplorata
però lui sa che in italia non ce la
farebbe allora prova di tutto e va lì e
infatti mio nonno lavora nelle grandi
miniere crea un sistema per portare aria
pulita aria fresca ai minatori delle
miniere d'oro e di diamanti presenti in
sudafrica e 70 anni dopo
siccome il destino curioso senso
dell'umorismo sony poté assieme altri
due soci creano un purificatore d'aria
naturale cleri e creare un prolifico
attore dare naturale che fonde natura
tecnologia e design
quindi sfruttiamo le proprietà di
fitodepurazione che alcune piante hanno
questo avviene nelle radici della pianta
dove ci sono microrganismi che
processano queste sostanze tossiche
formaldeide benzene tricot tilen e che
sono veramente molto pericolose per la
nostra salute e grazie al nostro sistema
a doppio vaso dotato di una unità
tecnologica dotata di ventole senso
riportiamo molta più aree nelle radici
della pianta
grazie sensori possiamo monitorare
quest'area e vedere
è esponenzialmente incrementare le
proprietà di fitodepurazione delle
piante e riusciamo ad abbattere un
nemico molto importante
l'inter pollution l'inquinamento da
interni l'idea nasce al politecnico di
milano dal mio socio vincenzo vitiello
che assieme al suo collega di università
alessio d'andrea creano il primo
prototipo lo presentano al salone del
mobile di qualche anno fa e ottengono un
primo successo però volevano portare
questo prodotto da prodotto ad azienda e
quindi sono venuti da me io lavoravo in
generali e avevo appena fondato tallinn
gardel pordenone un covo king face a
pordenone e mi hanno scelto io sono
sempre grato a loro per avermi scelto in
questa questa avventura questo viaggio
che stiamo facendo insieme ogni giorno
ci impegniamo tantissimo finché questo
viaggio continui e ottenga nuove mete e
quindi abbiamo deciso di fare questo
viaggio proprio perché avevamo un nemico
molto importante da battere
ovvero l'inter pollution l'inquinamento
interno è molto grave le persone pensano
che l'inquinamento sia solo all'esterno
ma non è così
la ms l'organizzazione mondiale della
sanità ha proprio certificato che
l'inquinamento interno può essere
addirittura cinque volte superiore a
quello esterno
il problema è che passiamo anche il 90
per cento del nostro tempo all'interno
quindi siamo continuamente esposti a
questo rischio formaldeide benzene
tricot thylane e come dicevo prima sono
comunissimi inquinanti ma veramente
molto dannosi per la nostra salute e
vengono emessi da banalissimi spray
detergenti finiture di mobili plastiche
e continuamente respiriamo quest'area in
pura ed è un gravissimo problema milioni
di persone muoiono ogni anno per colpa
di questo problema in paesi come gli
stati uniti india cina c'è maggiore
consapevolezza di questo problema ma qua
in italia in europa si fa ancora fatica
ma piano piano sta emergendo è quindi
forte di questo grande problema è un
prodotto altamente innovativo abbiamo
detto facciamo questo viaggio proviamoci
rischiamo purtroppo però sapevamo che
l'italia non era il posto ideale per
iniziare la nostra ventura e quindi
siamo andati nel posto che più di ogni
altro fa fiorire le start up
l'innovazione siamo andati in silicon
valley siamo andati volevamo andare al
city las vegas la fiera più importante
di tecnologia al mondo e siamo partiti
abbiamo fatto il nostro viaggio
siamo arrivati prima los angeles e
questa immagine molto importante perché
qua si parla di fortuna la fortuna sia
un amante esigente e la fortuna
componente veramente importante che
anche i grandi marinai di un tempo
sapevano che dovevano aver fortuna per
avere successo nella loro spedizione ma
è una variabile completamente
incontrollabile e io sono una persona
che crede tanto nel destino e ci siamo
trovati allo staple center di los
angeles il tempio del basket americano
dove giocano i famosissimi los angeles
lakers era l'intervallo e durante
l'intervallo c'è il famosissimo tiro da
centrocampo un fortunato spettatore può
tirare da centrocampo e se fa canestro
vince il jackpot era da diverse giornate
che non si faceva jackpot
il jackpot era circa di 100.000 dollari
e in quel momento lo stadio in totale
silenzio
riprende la palla io mi sono sentito lui
in quel momento io volevo che lui
facesse canestro
volevo che il destino mi nessun segnale
infatti fa partire la palla e fa
canestro
lo stadio esplode tutti contenti boati e
le persone dicevano alla key che
fortunato però seneca diceva che la
fortuna non esiste esiste il momento in
cui il talento incontra l'occasione e
noi il talento ce l'avevamo anche
dovevamo solo trovare l'occasione e
quindi siamo andati al ces di las vegas
è stata un'esperienza fantastica quattro
giorni meravigliosi dove abbiamo potuto
parlare del nostro prodotto il prodotto
piaceva a tutti investitori i
giornalisti distributori fornitori tutti
adoravano questo innovativo sistema per
depurare l'aria basato su una pianta una
vera pianta e quindi la cosa più
importante è stata che plug'n'play
ventures uno dei più importanti
investitori acceleratori della silicon
valley ci ha chiamato eravamo ancora a
las vegas ci ha chiamato ci ha detto
ragazzi abbiamo saputo del vostro
prodotto
venite subito nei nostri uffici a
sunnyvale palco sotto san francisco
perché vogliamo vedere noi subito siamo
partiti come dei missili
siamo andati là veramente contentissimi
e gli americani non si formalizzano più
di tanto un colloquio di 20 minuti hanno
visto il team hanno visto il prodotto
hanno detto fantastico questo prodotto è
fantastico il team fa benissimo
voi adesso state quattro mesi e lavorate
per far diventare questo prodotto
un'azienda e quindi questa era la prima
grande tappa del nostro viaggio
veramente molto importante mar anche una
tappa fondamentale dove bisognava
prendere una decisione
bisogna buttarsi e noi ovviamente era un
omone una situazione difficilissima
perché avevamo fatto la bella vita tra
los angeles e las vegas non avevamo più
soldi
eravamo eravamo praticamente allo sbando
cioè non ce lo aspettavamo ed eravamo in
un motel di quelli squallidissimi lungo
la statale abbiamo detto dobbiamo farlo
cioè dobbiamo buttarci facciamo questo
viaggio ovviamente sì abbiamo voluto
fare questo viaggio però mi ricordo che
una persona a me molto cara mi disse ma
paolo non hai non hai paura
se siete senza soldi hai il tuo bel
lavoro alle generali
avete le carte di credito bloccate ma
non hai paura e io le dissi no
assolutamente no perché io vedo il
futuro vedo il futuro di questo di
questa azienda di questo prodotto cioè
portare in alto questo prodotto sarà una
cosa meravigliosa
certo il presente mi spaventa perché
sarà pieno di difficoltà ma penso che
ogni imprenditore deve guardare il
futuro e non farsi condizionare dalle
difficoltà del presente e quindi questo
viaggio lo abbiamo iniziato
ovviamente ogni viaggio ha bisogno di
supporto come gli antichi marinai si
facevano sovvenzionare le spedizioni e
poi quando andavano bene riuscivano ad
autofinanziarsi anche noi abbiamo
bisogno ha bisogno avuto bisogno di un
iniziale supporto infatti ringrazierò
sempre la mia famiglia che mi ha aiutato
le mie sorelle ma soprattutto mia madre
che ha sempre creduto in me e mi ha
sempre supportato e ci aiutato in questa
prima fase ed è stato un viaggio
veramente meraviglioso perché è partito
da poco più di un anno ma abbiamo già
ottenuto risultati veramente incredibili
abbiamo raccolto circa 260.000 dollari
di preordini del prodotto in solo tre in
soli 30 giorni
adesso siamo arrivati a 360.000 abbiamo
vinto né european product design award
siamo stati chiamati al g20 di berlino
per parlare del nostro prodotto davanti
a diplomatici ministri decision makers e
ho avuto la fortuna di essere
selezionato tra i primi dieci
imprenditori
a livello globale under 30 è la cosa più
importante di tutti che è una notizia
freschissima e ci tengo a darla questa
platea è che abbiamo appena ricevuto un
investimento di circa 2 milioni di euro
dall'unione europea e questo farà sì che
questo viaggio continui e possiamo
ambire a mete a traguardi sempre più
elevati dove abbiamo innovato abbiamo
fatto un'innovazione tecnica è
un'innovazione di linguaggio
un'innovazione tecnica perché cleri è un
prodotto complesso è un prodotto dove
natura e tecnologia si sposano un unico
magnifico essere e quindi abbiamo dovuto
lavorare tanto su le piante quindi ci
siamo affidati alpina the lives uno dei
centri migliori di neurobiologia delle
piante che sono proprio le piante cioè
abbiamo la fortuna di averlo qua in
italia che anni hanno validato
l'efficacia del prodotto e ci hanno
detto che funzionava ma abbiamo dovuto
lavorare anche moltissimo sulla
tecnologia perché cleri ha un anima
tecnologica che implementa innalza le
capacità affitto depurative delle piante
e quindi abbiamo lavorato tantissimo
sull'hardware sul feedback sul firmware
per portare veramente un prodotto di
livello mondiale ma abbiamo fatto anche
un innovazione di linguaggio perché
cleri è un prodotto complesso è un
prodotto dove natura e tecnologia si si
mescolano e quindi dovevamo far capire
alle persone che questo prodotto poteva
andare a sostituire i tradizionali
purificatori d'aria naturali quelli in
plastica fatti con filtri meccanici che
vanno sostituiti ogni tre mesi
quindi dobbiamo andare a scardinare
l'archetipo di purificatore d'aria
tradizionale e ci siamo riusciti ma
quello che anche abbiamo dovuto fare
siccome cleri è fatto in ceramica
ceramica di nove vicino vicenza e noi ci
teniamo tantissimo
l'italianità e il made in italy del
nostro prodotto
ci teniamo veramente tanto vediamo che
l'italianità il made in italy è
veramente un valore aggiunto che tutto
il mondo ci apprezza ci invidia e quindi
quello che dovevamo fare era creare un
prodotto altamente innovativo ma che
avesse comunque un'anima tradizione di
tradizioni infatti perché il triveneto è
un territorio con
altissime tradizioni la cura dei
dettagli l'artigianato sono valori
altissimi che noi abbiamo cercato di
coniugare nel nostro prodotto e farlo
passare al mondo come un prodotto di
massa ma che potesse avere comunque un
anima artigianale e ci siamo riusciti e
quindi concludendo fare è stata
veramente è un viaggio bellissimo e
spero che continui ancora per tanto che
possiamo raggiungere tantissimi altri
obiettivi il mondo adesso però a nuove
sfide nuove problematiche da affrontare
però il mondo e anche più globalizzato
possiamo prendere un aereo essere in
silicon valley in 10 ore possiamo
lavorare con pressione a 10.000
chilometri di distanza possiamo fare
tutto però ci sono nuovi problemi che
vanno affrontati e io quello nel mio
piccolo che posso dare come consiglio a
chiunque voglia fare imprenditoria e
start up e di buttarsi e di guardare al
futuro e non farsi spaventare dal
presente e di andare a prendersi quel
futuro
grazie mille
[Applauso]